today we're going to discuss a very very
important topic um
what was that
dementia actually i'm going to show you
the number one vitamin deficiency
that mimics
dementia okay because
if you have this idea that you're
getting dementia or someone's telling
you you're getting dementia
it could be a simple vitamin deficiency
not the actual disease dementia and i
will point this out i've talked about in
other videos the worst thing to do is
if your spouse friend or family member
starts
forgetting things they start having
confusions or they're making all these
different mistakes to remind them of
that but that's actually one way to
cause them to make more and more
mistakes or forget things
all right what is the most important
vitamin uh for the brain okay and if
you're deficient can create
all sorts of cognitive problems well
that would be vitamin b12
b12 is from animal products so if you're
not consuming animal products you
probably are going to be deficient
unless you take it as a supplement
now i will say that b12 is also made by
microbes because
i did an evaluation on my wheatgrass
juice powder and it was kind of shocking
to find out there was b12 in wheatgrass
because grass doesn't make b12
it's the microbes that were in the grass
that made the b12 which is interesting
so you can get b12 from certain microbes
all right the other cause of a b12
deficiency is that
you don't have enough hydrochloric acid
in your stomach now that happens as we
age it can also happen if you're taking
an antacid you need
strong hydrochloric acid to be able to
absorb b12
so that's another little thing
to be aware of one symptom of low
hydrochloric acid is acid reflux okay
if that surprises you
you should probably watch that video
that i did on that topic after you're
done with this one
now one of the cause of a b12 deficiency
would be the side effect of metformin
all right so when you take metformin you
become deficient in not just b12 but
vitamin b1 as well now in the studies in
b12 when they gave people b12
with people that already had a
deficiency in omega-3 fatty acids
b12 didn't seem to work but when you
have enough of this omega-3 fatty acid
called dha
then b12 worked very very well so in
other words you need the omega-3 fatty
acid
to allow b12 to work so you need both of
these for brain function
another really
common cause of dementia
are the side effects from
medications
especially antacids
bladder medications for bladder control
sleep aids antidepressants medication
for anxiety cholesterol medication okay
statins
blood pressure medications cortical
steroids
and alcohol
so in other words if you're starting to
get dementia symptoms
and you're on some of these medications
get that medication out and start
looking at the side effects it could be
as simple as some medication that is
causing you to have dementia in fact
it's very very common i mean can you
imagine not really evaluating these side
effects right and then you have dementia
and you're on another medication for
that that potentially can give you
another side effect that you take
another medication for i'm telling you
there are so many side effects that are
then camouflaged with other medications
and there's no way to know if your
symptom is coming from that unless you
come off that medication of course check
with your doctor there's several other
really important vitamin deficiencies
and a mineral deficiency that is related
to dementia that you have to be aware of
b1 is a very common one
especially with the area of the brain
that's involved with memory loss and
that would be the hippocampus the
hippocampus is the part of the brain
that's involved with
memories now they don't know exactly
what it does but they do know when the
hippocampus shrinks and has
neurodegeneration or atrophy then you
get alzheimer's and not just a b12
deficiency
but a b1 deficiency can actually create
damage of the hippocampus it can create
the same damage as a lack of oxygen
hypoxia okay so b1 is very very
important
it's important as a cofactor in the
metabolism of the mitochondria that
generates energy for the brain so
without b1 the nerves cannot work and
you literally starve off the fuel for
the brain
and the number one cause of the b1
deficiency is consuming too much sugar
or carbohydrates you see the more
carbohydrate that you give the brain to
run on the more b1 you you need so the
high carb diets increase the demand for
b1 and so usually people don't have
enough b1 and so that creates more of a
deficiency and now you're left with a
situation where your hippocampus starts
to suffer it starts to break down and
then you're having problems with memory
uh locating things
confusion
coming up with solution to problems zinc
is another key nutrient involved with
hippocampus if you have a zinc
deficiency
you'll have a tendency to develop
amyloid plaquing in the brain which you
see in alzheimer's
now how do you become zinc deficient
probably also because you're consuming
too much sugar or carbs
but also something called phytic acid
phytic acid is in the grains it's in the
breads it's in the pasta it's in the
crackers so that phytic acid blocks zinc
which can then cause these symptoms
right here so zinc is an another
important nutrient and then we have
vitamin d okay
if you're deficient in vitamin d which
most the population is deficient you can
go from a mild form of dementia to a
severe
form of dementia a lot faster so vitamin
d
slows
the process of developing
damage in your brain and of course
vitamin d comes from the sun it's very
difficult to get it from the food but
it's in fatty fish dairy it's in cod
liver oil it's also in mushrooms but not
to a large degree so if you have signs
and symptoms of dementia
this is what i would recommend okay i
would recommend getting on a keto diet
immediately okay the healthy version
with fasting because out of all the
things that you can do running the the
brain on ketones
would be the best thing you could do
because it'll bypass the damage in the
hippocampus and feed the neurons
directly from a different way and
actually
help slow down this degeneration
number two
fish fatty fish and seafood okay seafood
will give you the zinc it will also give
you the omega-3 fatty acids dha but also
fatty fish like salmon will also give
you both of those nutrients as well as
vitamin d
red meat for b12
another important thing but if you're
deficient in b12 red meat will give you
all you need
now this other thing with the stomach if
your stomach acids are not strong enough
this is a really good remedy it's called
betaine hydrochloride you want to take
like five of these right before you have
a meal and that will slowly start
building up the acid in the stomach as
well as the absorption of b12 so this is
a really good plan if you're starting to
get this symptom of um
what is that
dementia
now if you haven't seen my video on b12
that would be the next video to watch i
put it up right here check it out